hey we had this big conversation about
how you weren't gonna give me anything
for my birthday because I didn't give
you anything for your birthday and then
once you'd show up at our office but
nerdfighters the actual original video
game I'm a very happy person right now
thank you I'd like to announce my
retirement from writing and the fact
that I'm going to become a full doll I
may not be ready to be a full time Aero
fighters player because as soon as I
announce my retirement I lost so ain't
good news and bad news the bad news is
that I'm now hundreds of miles away from
the amazing birthday present you got me
ah-ah-ah
the good news is that I'm back in
Pittsburgh on the set of the dippy O's
movie so I always thought that when they
made movies by the way this is Ben
Richardson the cinematographer of the
movie I always thought when they made
movies and there's like seven different
angles in a shot that it was seven
different cameras you know but it turns
out there's just one very expensive
camera seven different times exactly
this was one of the great delights of my
life is trying to explain this principle
to my mom the tricky thing is if we had
another camera right now for the shots
that we just got the cameras would be
right there in front of the key of
course no I realized that now Ben
there's Deb she does the action one of
the weird rules in making the movies
we're actually not allowed to do
anything until Deb hits the slate like I
can't eat until hey and if I want to go
to the bathroom by the way I was just
like why do all these cars have Indiana
license plates and then I remembered
because of the movie so I think I always
thought that making movies with super
glamorous but it turns out that it's
mostly just a construction site however
there is one very glamorous facet to the
moviemaking process I'm referring of
course to the porta-potties I mean I
think I've lived in apartment smaller
than this porta potti it has both a
toilet and a urinal
it also smells great here by the way it
smells like angels and Stardust I'm
serious this is a fancy porta potti also
there's free food including atomic
fireballs did you see that Josh I did
should we have that should we have NAT
maybe eat this right before he kisses
Monica for the first time
I'm here with Isaac and Alex Isaac and
Alex and they were just saying that I
should Charlie
I should just stand in for Ansel I am
Gus I mean he
older than you it's like the Olsen twins
but of course most of my time on set is
still spent watching and listening
although now with NAT Wolff making
trouble in the background no NAT I love
you too so like one of my favorite
things about the movie so far is that
they cast real teen cancer survivors for
the support group they're waving to you
right now in fact and I want to thank
all of them for being part of the movie
and also for sharing their experiences
with us it's just been awesome to hang
out with them mind if I send this TMZ I
tell you what's funniest about that I
turn the camera away when you answer the
phone because you're such a good actress
that I thought you were really on the
phone
that's just pure talent I'm here with
Ansel Elgort who's playing Gus in the
fall nurse to first movie and has a
futon we're gonna do like a quick
question Tuesday and then people can
submit questions and maybe we'll do
another question Tuesday in the future
with real questions but the question I
get the most often is have you read the
book yeah I read it
did you what do you think it was all
right yeah a little it was long and
weighs lovely I loved it I loved it
and then I think we got to get hit by a
car
nightmare scenario what's your last
memory Ansel Elgort beautiful hand on my
shoulder did you read the book
people ask you that all the time though
like they think you haven't read the
book I've read the book I read the book
multiple times it's definitely one of my
favorite books meaning that it's kind of
my second favorite no not my my it's in
my top two favorite books ever behind I
have to say that I really love 1984 we
got to go apparently because somebody is
about to make out not me but I'll see
you on Friday and so can you say I'll
see you on Friday see you on Friday Hank
hasta luego amigos